I had an MRI done as my cancer antigen numbers keep going up so first of all defining
terms cancer antigen numbers are your tumor marker numbers keep going up my brain is clear
I presume that means the MRI showed the brain is clear but shows signs of bone metastasis
so I presume this person say their MRI is showing signs of body metastasis
the negolace is up the negolace is a test some totally different test negolace numbers
are up a small bit but still in the normal range
I was it was in my spine to begin with yet had gone invisible
I assume that your meaning that the metastasis was in your spine to begin with but that wasn't
visible on some scan maybe the MRI maybe a PET scan I'm not sure
if this person is on you may want to reformulate that to help us understand that a little bit
bead it is showing again what do you suggest for changing up
again I'm not fully understanding that the tumor marker has elevated
so remember you don't you don't make make decisions based upon just one test so if the tumor
marker is elevated yet the MRI is clear I don't I'm not exactly sure what
I don't understand this but in general if you're going to if you're going to make some changes
in your protocol based upon your objective or subjective findings changing so if you have a
changing objective findings like the you know there's different markers that are showing a greater
degree in metastasis or something like that or you're not feeling as well your teeth is increased
you have increase in pain along with some blood test changes etc then yeah it's always good to check
to see if we should change things up so do we need to change the rife settings maybe do we need to
is there a best healing journey for the bones what could you do for that so let's kind of walk
through this so number one one way that you can change things up and know what you should do to change
things up would be to do another jigswap test so through another jigswap test and we could look at your
protocol dietary protocols supplement protocol to see if we need to change things up we also will see
if we need to change the rife settings you also make decisions on changing the rife settings based
upon other things too so first of all if you want to add some bone healing programs to your rife
anybody can message me and ask for those I wrote a new bone set program it's some short programs
for bone building if that's if you have metastasis to bone and you have body involvement those could be
helpful but again I always think that it's best to run the cancer programs because the reason why you
have erosion of a bone if you have metastasis to bone is because the cancer so it's not about just we
need to build up the bone and get counseling into the bone and get the bone healed we need to kill the
cancer that's causing the destruction are there some nutritional things in general that are good
to help build bone yes of course you always think of calcium to build bone but I think it's a mistake
when people are taking high dose calcium so when you have an increased bone loss either due to osteoporosis
or osteopaedia that is not pathological or you have pathological bone loss because of metastasis to
bone and body destruction because most metastasis to bone is going to be is going to be lytic it's going
to be breaking down bone you first state that we need to really increase the calcium we need to be
taking a thousand fifteen hundred milligrams of calcium and the studies are shown that that's not
the right thing to do you really need to increase a type of vitamin K called vitamin mk4 now a lot of
vitamin K's on the market are going to be the mk7 mk7 is a general absorption of calcium that's what vitamin
K does but it's mk4 that gets the calcium into the bone so we have a product out there that's called
osteo K osteo e bone dash K and it's very high dose mk4 with just I think a couple couple
capsules is like 250 or something milligrams of calcium so it's really the right dose of calcium
with very high doses of mk4 so if you have destruction of bone for any reason whether it's
non-pathological osteoporosis osteopaedia or it's pathological meaning that you have destruction
because of metastasis to bone then taking osteo K is the right thing to do it's the right dose of calcium
with the correct dose of mk4 there is no other supplement on the market that has that alone of mk4
we still have a bone-building bundle we still have a bone-building bundle it also has a couple
of other supplements in there that's really good for the bone which is the TVGO the TVGO is
EGCG supplement why would you take EGCG for bone-building because it decreases inflammation at the
periosteum so that's why you would take that I can't remember what else is in that bundle but
it's really that osteo K to help build bones and TVGO are the two most important ones